hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan this is a
special edition brought to you by Telus
they have launched a campaign where
they're giving $100,000 away to a
Canadian entrepreneur I'll talk a little
bit about it at the end of the video so
stay tuned for the end in this episode
I'm going to answer question from one of
our Telus talks business readers who
wrote in asking about how to increase
sales so the question was thanks for the
advice I'm also running a company but
struggling to increase my sales cash
flow and I'm failing to pay my suppliers
and my bank loans in time I need more of
your good advice because I want to make
a breakthrough so thank you for that
question really tough situation and a
lot of entrepreneurs do get themselves
in a huge cash crunch by spending more
than they're making and that that is
often a recipe for failure and I want to
you know really feel for you and I hope
that you can get out of this I'm gonna
give you some tips too to help you go
through that
the first thing is really stop spending
money and anybody can spend money this
is what we saw a lot with my venture
capital days
anybody can spend money it's not hard to
spend money they gave me a million bucks
you can go out and spend a million bucks
if you you get the hundred thousand
dollars from tell us if so you can go
out and find a hundred thousand ways to
use it but not only buddy can make money
and so the important thing to do as an
entrepreneur is try to make money before
you're spending money I hate spending
money until I'm making money and I'll
invest my time and energy in new
projects and trying to get them to go
wait before I'll spend my money and that
should be the approach so I think you
should take and a lot of entrepreneurs
should take look for ways to spend your
time and energy to go out and earn money
but don't spend your money to do it once
you see that you can make the work on a
small scale then it's okay to spend
money to experience you know what's
working but at the beginning don't spend
money a quick example even with these
YouTube videos that you guys are
watching go back to my earlier videos
and they were really bad right a lot of
it was because I didn't want to spend
money to invest in the equipment to
create the videos until I knew that I
was going to commit to it and there was
a potential
revenue model down the down the line for
me so the first videos are really bad
it's on a really old camera the lighting
is terrible the audio was terrible the
content was still pretty good but the
you know the money that would be spent
on video editing and having a nice
camera and happy to do microphone and
have a good lighting that is much better
in the videos now I started to spend
money on that once I started making
money from the videos and it was as
simple as that so I used the momentum
from the early days to get it going
don't spend a lot of money and then as I
started making my name is able to invest
back into the business and was able to
build it up and it's not that I couldn't
have spent money to buy a camera and
lighting it's just it's easy to go and
spend money on new projects that never
take off so I always try to make sure
that I'm finding a way to make money on
these projects I'll guess my time into
it and energy but I won't spend money
until I find a way to make some of that
money back so that's kind of step one
that can be kind of general advice and
oh how do i implement that the next
thing is go off their companies and
build around them so try to build your
product your service around customers so
I don't know what you're selling didn't
mention in your comment but go out and
try to find guys and talk to them
potential customers will pay you to
solve their problem the more you can
build your product or service around
somebody who has a problem in willing to
pay you for it the better your cash flow
is gonna be right so we made this
mistake in my first software company we
spent all this time building this one
feature that as it turns out nobody
really wanted and I was an awesome
feature but we thought it was awesome
but our customers didn't really care and
so what was the point of that if we had
spoken to our customers earlier in find
out what they wanted and build around
their pain points and their problems we
would have had the more money coming in
we would have been a more successful
company earlier on I know luckily we had
enough good features in our software
that people still wanted to buy from us
but the the one thing we spent so much
time working on nobody cared and I think
a lot of entrepreneurs have that same
thing where they spend a lot of time and
energy on something that people don't
really care that much about you're not
really solving a problem so you want to
talk to your customers build around what
their problems are and you
have a study no cash flow coming in it's
great if you can talk to companies
instead of individuals because if you
can have had a blast and impact with the
company they're gonna hire you back it's
gonna be bigger dollars it's gonna be
ongoing commitment and they're likely to
tell their you know other companies
about you as well so it's great to have
those relationships we're selling to
consumers can be really tough where they
may love it but they'll buy much smaller
quantities won't have as much need for
you so it's a lot harder to do consumer
oriented business than business and the
last tip would be to start with a
service and I don't know if you're
selling a service or if you're selling a
product but I definitely geared toward
to serve this notion of you know cash
crunch his service doesn't cost you a
lot of money it's your time which
eventually you want to you know try to
break free of but at the beginning you
got to get to survival or you got to get
the point where you're able to make you
know enough money to pay your bills you
pay your bank pay your suppliers and
you're making you know a comfortable
living so you gotta get to that survival
point and a lot of entrepreneurs never
hit that and that's why they have to
shut down so a great way to do that
start a service talk to companies again
solve their problems do it with the
service do it with investing a lot of
time into it and as you get closer to
your companies and close to your
customers you really understand their
needs and the needs of the market then
you're able to introduce a product that
can help them even more and you can
expand part companies are typically more
expensive take longer to get going have
a higher failure rate then if you can
start with a service really you'll get a
cash flow stream coming in and be able
to build on that then your bigger vision
may be to have products on the line but
I'd start with the service especially if
you're in a cash crunch and in the last
point is just your your income is gonna
depend on how much value you provide to
your customers so the more value
provides your customers the more money
you're gonna be able to make if you need
more money faster provide more value
faster it's really as simple as that
entrepreneurs will make as much money as
they're able to the charge more because
they're offering a lot more value if
you're not able to get the prices that
you want because you're not giving your
customers enough value so look for ways
to add incredible overwhelming value to
ideally business customers and it's a
service
and hopefully I'll get you you'll get
your company off to that next level and
get you out of this cash crunch that
you're facing
hopefully that was really helpful again
this video is sponsored by Telus they
have a challenge going on where they are
giving away $100,000 of Canadian
entrepreneur you can enter at the global
male slash the challenge and I'm gonna
be one of the judges we're looking at
the end of May to be able to give away
this money so check it out I'd love to
see you guys there if you did like this
video please give it a thumbs up below
and love seeing those come in it always
makes my day when when you do that so
thank you and if you have any questions
about this video or other questions to
your business feel free to leave it in
the comments below I always check those
out and I'd be happy to answer for you
as well so thank you and we'll see you
on the next episode
you